okay [ __ ] okay franchezca we're
playing again Black Mesa ok basically
have like water but with the game engine
and graphics a half life 2 so let's just
do that spent you know let's just do
this bench I like to say yeah let's just
see here I'm like a bigger some settings
gonna kind of figure these some bad
judge enough okay I'm just gonna keep it
real who's Jake you out light where it's
gonna keep it classy okay okay there we
go let's do this no game yes yes it
let's do our chapter watch how I ok ok
um so I have their bones weekend been
good the heck out girl [ __ ] here is
Black Mesa I got got got married oh
where is Gary
[Music]
all the train again oh man
ok
marg a menace [ __ ] is that how's New
Mexico good morning and welcome to the
black lace gemara a good learning this
automated training is provided for the
security and convenience of the Black
Mesa research facility Caroline says the
time is 847 am current Papa died kappa
derby is 93 degrees I got ninja with an
estimated high hundred you think a lot
of workers spotted calm and all this
must be trouble future this is a
American a chopped America
okay we might get off this one day or
just how does is this the game I guess
that's what the game okay lettings
chaotic [ __ ] forgot yeah I'll bet slot
it okay got other guys talking plumber
said i don't know i don't know ki can we
get some weapons ok show me the crowbar
this train is inbound
well little three dormitories to sector
C test labs and control facilities if
your intended destination on a Saturday
area I hardly work in Sector C you'll
need to return to the central transit
have a lot of work in this was Terry and
I and board high-security train
if you have not yet submitted to
identity salute no clearance system you
must report the Black Mesa personnel
before you will be permitted into the
high security branch of the transit
system
come on [ __ ] look red I love Brad with
pretty other
it's got out here yet do it for high
toxicity of material routinely handled
in the Black Mesa compound no is smoking
eating or drinking are permitted within
the Black Mesa Transit System Franco
operator Pillinger
got me working out here
ah
okay please keep your limbs inside the
train at all times of map do not attempt
to open the doors until the train has
come to a complete halt at the station
platform in the event of an emergency
passengers as you remain seated and
await for this thousand bucket one if it
is necessary to exit the Train disabled
personnel should be evacuated first stay
away from electrified rail and proceed
to rehire you should until assistance
collide I check your other skin can I
shows better than [ __ ] out much
[Music]
ok
[Music]
make that come on Nick it's all I
come on that
he [ __ ] cell phone at home
tomato I found me out
I got ya
okay nice and tight nice and pie okay
[Music]
this is all [ __ ] no man dr. Fargo sahaja
course decathlon will commence this
evening plant 1900 hours to the level 3
facility the semi-finals of the high
security personnel will be announced in
deference secure broadcast transmission
remember more lives indoors may depend
on your fitness I'm a research associate
thank you I look at this satellite hey
baby MMA I stick my dick a nice
[Music]
and yes
you have a friend or relative who would
make a valuable addition to the Black
Mesa team immediate openings are
available in the areas of material
handling and clearing security yeah
contact what makes a personnel
under information
if you have an associate for the
background
theoretical physics biotechnology [ __ ]
along as esta página contact a civilian
recruiting team
the facility is an equal opportunity
employer
[Music]
hey
yeah and looks like my sex life my
second ex I said there we go what's
going on here and it can't be spent on
the all day [ __ ] long asking you to
work chef shanita [ __ ] man x2 plays
banjo a reminder to all black mesa
personnel why regular radiation and
biohazard see I'm fair amount with the
walking employment in the Black Mesa
research facility missing a schedule of
your analysis
[Music]
that's what gets over there what
your future depends on it
we supposed to be like going through
this your idea fool
[Music]
now evolving facility please stand back
from the automated door and wait for the
security officer to verify backup lockup
blaker or exiting the Train be sure to
check your area for personal belongings
thank you and have a very safe and
productive day that's Chavous how can
load securing that's a lot it's great I
think loads can shows up in the thing
OBS thought oh well Wow morning mr.
Tremont bagging my name looks like
you're running late thinkstock and flush
out outside and pretty cares about these
parts yes its bark at let the father
caught up with up already I'm freaking
out what's been happening at Steph
Freeman you Laden up a bit that's knock
out that your mom was like
it's out for Harambee
[Music]